delays in washington in the push for a
social spending package as president
biden visits europe mr biden is at the
vatican this morning meeting with pope
francis this is the fourth time those
two men have met back in washington
meanwhile democrats are working on a cut
down version of his ambitious agenda as
a self-imposed deadline approaches
wijajang is traveling with the president
we find her in rome italy this morning
weisha good morning to you
benjorner to you tony and good morning
to everybody president biden had hoped
that lawmakers would reach an agreement
on his social spending measure before
coming here to italy in fact he even
made a last-minute visit to capitol hill
to give one final push before leaving
but in the end he presented that smaller
version of his plan there is still work
to do though to seal the deal
president biden left for his european
trip right after declaring he had
reached an historic framework with
democrats for a 1.75 trillion dollar
social spending bill the agenda that's
in these bills is what 81 million
americans voted for the revised package
does not include some of the president's
original priorities like paid family
leave and free community college also
gone an expansion of medicare to cover
vision and dental care but the bill as
it stands would still establish
universal pre-k and extend the child
care tax credit for one year it would
also boost the supply of affordable
housing expand medicaid to cover four
million more people and includes more
than 550 billion dollars to fight
climate change we spent hours and hours
and hours over months and months working
on this
no one got everything they wanted
including me
treasury secretary janet yellen who is
also in rome praised the compromise it
will make it much easier for people to
participate in the workforce by
providing child care and support for
people who work the president said he is
confident he has the votes to pass the
plan but two moderate democrats
arizona's kirsten cinema and west
virginia's joe manchin have yet to voice
their full support
still house speaker nancy pelosi wanted
democrats to vote on the president's one
trillion dollar infrastructure deal
thursday but house progressives insisted
they will only vote to approve both
measures together the win will be when
we deliver both bills that is the win
for us and from washington to rome
president biden has a packed schedule
planning to meet with italian president
sergio matarella and prime minister
mario draghi as well as french president
emmanuel macron cbs news papal and
vatican contributor monsignor anthony
figuerado says it's the president's
meeting with the pope that is both
political and deeply personal pope
francis wishes to build bridges
not walls it's not rare for an american
president to meet with the pope but why
is this particular meeting different
obviously they share a common faith
and personal suffering so i think
there's instantly going to be a body
chemistry between the two
president biden will remain here in rome
through the weekend before heading to
scotland for a big climate summit on
sunday back in washington funding for
highway programs was set to expire on
sunday which would have furloughed
thousands of workers now that's partly
why there was such an urgency to pass
the infrastructure bill just in case
that does not happen the house has
passed a short-term measure to continue
funding those programs through december
nate
still so much to be done and still so
much at stake ouija thank you